We're in 1646 and as I explained last time,
the development of the war,
especially between 1643 and 45 had unleashed forces which could not easily be
controlled and created aims and expectations which had not originally existed at
the outbreak of war,
especially the controversy concerning the future organization of the Church and
the issue of liberty of conscience.
Um,
parliament was now severely divided between those who wanted to Presbyterian
church settlement and the so called independence,
who favored liberty of conscience was the defeat of the king.
These issues,
we're now prominent in establishing the terms of settlement and as they
attempted a settlement,
the fundamental differences of perception of the nature of the parliamentary
cause.
What it had been,
what it was now came very much to the fore
in 1646 to seven,
the so called Presbyterian group where the dominant group in parliament,
they held the initiative.
And in July,
1646 they put two King Charles,
who was now in the north of England,
held by the Scots in Newcastle.
They put to him the Newcastle propositions.
Under those terms,
the kings should take the covenant.
There should be a United Presbyterian church for both England and Scotland.
Parliament was to control the military for 20 years,
which they thought was roughly the Kings expected lifetime and 58 of the king
supporters were to be exempted from pardon on the grounds that they had
committed various atrocities in the course of the war.
Charles faced with these terms played for time.
He might've lost militarily,
but he knew that they still needed him for any settlement.
Remember what the out of Manchester had said back in 1644 if we beat the King 90
and nine times,
he is king still.
Charles knew that
in February,
1647 the Scots army was paid off by the English parliament.
They handed over the king into English custody and they withdrew back to
Scotland and the king was brought south and lodged in the country house in North
Hampton,
share northwest of London home be house where negotiations continued.
Meanwhile,
the new model army,
which was now for the most part billeted in eastern England near Cambridge,
the new model army was ordered either to disband or to re enlist for service in
Ireland where the Irish confederacy was still in control.
This demand provoked an army,
many of whom were already worried by the prospect of a settlement which would be
intolerant in matters of religion and the consequences of that provocation where
momentous
in April and May,
1647 the cavalry regiments of the new model elected representatives,
they were called agitators.
They elected agitators and a council of the army was formed,
which consisted of the general officers,
the colonels of the regiments and the representatives of the various regiments.
Then on the 4th of June,
a junior officer corner,
Joyce went to home be house and sees the king and brought him to the army.
The famous story that when Joyce arrived at home,
because the guard there ask him where his warrant was to remove the king and he
drew his pistol and said,
here is my warrant.
Then on the 14th of June,
the army issued and printed a declaration.
They declared themselves to be no mirror mercenary army,
but an army enlisted to defend our own and the people's just rights and
liberties.
They demanded an act of oblivion to wipe away all acts which had been committed
during the war.
Pardon for all acts committed.
They demanded liberty for tender consciences as they put it in matters of
religion and the army leaders with the council began drawing up their own terms
for negotiation with the king whom they now held.
Then in late July,
1647 demonstrations in London on behalf of Presbyterianism and against the
armies actions led to the independent members of parliament fleeing the city.
They fled to the army and asked for its protection.
On the 6th of August,
the army marched south and occupied London,
restoring them to parliament from which some of their Presbyterian enemies fled.
Now then it was the turn of the army and the independence in parliament to
attempt a settlement with the king and they put to him terms which we're
entitled,
the heads of the proposals.
They were drawn up by Henry [inaudible],
a former lawyer who was the commissary general of the new model and John
Lambert,
one of the cavalry kernels,
and they will probably the most generous terms.
While there was certainly the most generous terms ever offered two King Charles,
remarkably so.
In fact,
the army insisted that in future there would be a parliament elected every two
years and that control of the militia would be with parliament,
but only 10 years,
not 20 they exempted only five royalists from,
pardon?
They were even willing to permit the reestablishment of a church of England with
bishops and the old prayer book,
but it should have no coercive powers over those who preferred other forms of
worship.
So reestablished church of England,
but with liberty for 10 to consciences Charles His aid and the negotiations
should say,
John Barclay urged the king to accept these proposals.
He said,
never would a kingdom last be so easily recovered as on such terms.
But the king temporized a Barclay later recorded in his memoirs that in his
view,
the king would not agree because he didn't trust well and item.
The reason he didn't trust them was that they asked for nothing for themselves,
but most likely the king was simply playing for time and secretly opening
negotiations at this time with the Scots who were increasingly alarmed now that
they'd withdrawn from England at what was happening in England and at the
prospect of independence in power.
Meanwhile,
while this was going on,
a further set of proposals began gestating amongst the agitators and the Army
Council and some of the officers,
and these were deeply influenced by the views of the London radical movement.
The levelers,
uh,
the level is led by John Little Lilburn,
William Wallin,
Richard Overton and John Wildman had emerged initially as pamphleteers on behalf
of liberty of conscience,
but their experience at the hands of an intolerant,
Presbyterian dominated parliament led them to,
began questioning the whole basis of government authority and the manner in
which the hands of power might be tied in,
in a number of respects.
They claimed in their pamphlets to speak on behalf of what they called the
middle and poorer sort of people,
the hob nails,
the cloud shoes,
the private soldiers,
the leather and wool and Aprils and all the laborious and industrious people of
England.
Very distinctly populist stance and they advanced the claim.
I'm coating that all power is originally and essentially in the whole body of
the people of this nation.
Declaration of popular sovereignty.
Accordingly,
they put forward proposals including a single chamber parliament.
They would abolish the House of Lords,
a redistribution of parliamentary seats in order to make them more equitable
elections to be held every two years with a much wider male suffrage,
quite how wide is debatable.
They probably held a variety of different views of different times.
Some appear to have been for full manhood,
suffrage,
others for a more limited suffrage,
but certainly a larger one.
The full disestablishment of the church,
thorough reform of the legal system,
the laws to be simplified and to be printed in English.
Well in October,
1647 much of this was drawn up in a set of proposals called the agreement of the
people and the agreement of the people having been debated a amongst them and
printed was then put forward to the army council in a set of debates which took
place in Putney church and then known as the Putney debates.
We have the full transcript of the Putney debates and it's a quite remarkable
survival.
The secretary of the army counsel took the whole thing down in shorthand and
this was rediscovered in the late 19th century and is now fully available in
print.
In the Putney debates,
we've,
we find fully transcribed the statements not only of the leaders of the army
council,
but also the Indi Independent,
um,
interjections expressing their aspirations of nameless soldiers who had been
elected on behalf of their regiments.
The secretary of the army counsel didn't know their names,
he put them down as buff coat.
I a man wearing a thick buff colored leather coat of a cavalryman or in one case
Bedfordshire man,
a man who either had a Bedfordshire accent perhaps,
or perhaps was wearing the sash of the Bedfordshire regimen.
Some of the statements made our most extraordinary ringing declarations.
General item,
who did most of the talking on behalf of the officers thought that all men
should enjoy liberty under the law,
but he took the view conventional for a man of his class that the votes should
only belong to people of property.
Those with a permanent and fixed interest in the kingdom.
In contrast to that view,
Thomas rain borough,
an artillery officer replied the poorest he that is in England hath a life to
live as the greatest he.
Therefore,
sir,
I truly think that every man that is to live under a government ought first by
his own consent to put himself under that government
item appealed to the importance of constitutional tradition in going forward
with the settlement.
2% Spi urged considering the reasonableness of the thing rather than
constitutional precedent.
Well,
the Putney debates are well worth reading,
and they provide an astonishing insight into the ideas which was circulating in
London and the army ideas generated by the experience of the war,
by the sense of possibility,
which had been unleashed upon among people who had been brought to ask as
several data ask in the Putney debates what half the soldier fought for.
That's a phrase that repeatedly comes to the fore in the course of the debates,
and they tell us a lot about the army leaders to the Lord General.
Thomas Fairfax was largely silent.
Fairfax was a professional soldier,
not a politician.
He was famously taciturn and he said little,
he merely acted as chairman.
Henry [inaudible] did most of the debating.
He was clearheaded very highly intelligent,
sharp.
He clearly became exasperated with what he saw as the Utopian schemes being put
forward by the soldiers.
Uh,
at one point,
he replied to the question,
what are the soldier fought for by saying,
I will tell you what the seller has fought for.
That one man's will shall not be law.
That was items perception of the conflict,
but he also declared himself willing to follow where God might lead.
Cranwell was something of a mediating figure.
He said comparatively little was characteristic of his manner.
He tended often when major decisions were to be made to hesitate,
to wait,
to wait on a sign from God and then when he was sure of his course of action to
take drastic action.
Well,
we're the general officer's seriously the negotiating with the representatives
of the regiments or whether they just humoring the troops to maintain order and
coherence and the army while pressing ahead with their own negotiations with the
king.
We'll never really know because ultimately it came to nothing.
The debates broke up in conclusively and the reason they broke up was because of
an action on the part of the king.
Charles was very much aware of the possibilities of exploiting potential
divisions on the parliamentarian side.
He was also very fearful of the radicals and what might happen if they were to
gain the ascendancy in the army council.
On the 11th of November,
he escaped from custody,
went south and took refuge on the isle of wight off the south coast of England.
There he was held by the parliamentarian governor in honorable custody,
but he was allowed to receive representatives and they included representatives
from Scotland
on the 15th of November.
Faced with this situation,
Fairfax and Cranwell called the army to a rendezvous and discipline was
reimposed chrom well road up and down the ranks,
plucking copies of the agreement of the people from the hat,
bands of some of the soldiers who'd come with copies of the agreement of the
people in their hats.
One in trangent and soldier was some early court marshaled and shot.
Okay.
In December,
1647 the king meanwhile concluded an agreement with Scott's representatives.
It was called the engagement in the engagement he undertook to accept a
Presbyterian church in return for military aid and he also began secretly
negotiation negotiating with the Irish confederacy.
Shortly afterwards.
In the spring of 1648 there were concerted royalist uprisings in various parts
of the Kingdom in Wales,
in south Wales,
in Kent,
in Essex,
and in the north in Yorkshire.
Meanwhile,
Charles,
his supporters in Scotland,
the engages,
began assembling an army for the invasion of England to deliver the king.
And with that,
the second civil war began.
So after so much hope of a settlement,
so much generosity in the terms which had been offered to Charles in the heads
of the proposals,
this renewal of the war hardened hearts of the army's leaders
on the 29th of April,
1648 they called the whole army to a general assembly at Windsor to the west of
London for a prayer meeting before they divided into various bodies,
each of which was to take on the royalist threat in different areas of the
kingdom.
And the mood at Windsor was very different from that.
At Putney.
The mood was one of heightened religious anxiety,
anger and expectation amongst men who had not wanted or expected to fight again.
They saw the renewal of the war as being both a judgment from God upon their
previous actions and a test of their resolve.
And they resolved that Charles was a man against whom God has witnessed and
quoting from the declaration which ended the meeting and therefore that it was
our duty if ever.
The Lord brought us back to peace to call Charles Stewart,
that man of blood to an account for that blood.
He had the shed and the miss chief.
He has done to his utmost against the Lord's cause and people in these poor
nations.
And in that mood,
the army departed Fairfax to the east chrome,
well first whales and then to the north where on the 17th to the 19th of July he
met and utterly shattered a much larger Scottish royalist army.
At the battle of Preston,
a heart fought,
fought running battle,
which stretched for miles along the road from Preston to Manchester.
Cromwells saw that victory as divinely ordained in the dispatch he sent back.
He could see nothing but the hand of God in it as he put it.
God had spoken again as far as he was concerned and the army began returning
slowly to London in a mood of Religious Exaltation Pausing in Yorkshire to mop
up royalist resistance at Pontefract castle before proceeding south that the
brief seizure Pontefract Thomas rain grow.
Uh,
the leveler,
um,
was killed.
But meanwhile parliament had reopen negotiations with the king.
The king was king still.
This proved too much for the officers in London on the 6th of December,
1648 Colonel Thomas Pride station troops at the entrance to the House of Commons
and conducted what's known as prides purge.
He refused to allow into parliament.
Anyone who did not sympathy sympathize with the army's cause.
Parliament was reduced to only 150 members known as the rump
while this was going on.
Cranwell was mysteriously absent.
He returned to London only after prides purge had been completed exactly where
he was.
Isn't certain,
um,
it's possible that he'd gone home to Huntington ship.
That's one idea.
He seems to have been undergoing one of those periods of reflection before
deciding on decisive action,
which were very characteristic of him.
But once he came back,
he was prominent in driving things ahead.
On the 1st of January,
1649 the rump,
the remaining hundred and 50 members of parliaments set up a high court of
justice to try the king.
The House of Lords refuse to participate.
The House of Commons therefore declared that its own decisions would have the
force of law since the people are under God.
The original of all just power.
On the 20th of January,
Charles the first was arraigned,
the charge,
I'm quoting,
declaring him to be a tyrant,
a traitor and murderer and a public and implacable enemy to the Commonwealth of
England.
The king with great dignity attended his trial in Westminster Hall,
but refused to recognize the authority of the court.
He was condemned on the 29th of January,
only 59 of the more than 150 members of the court could be prevailed upon to
actually sign the king's death warrant.
And then the following day the king was executed.
On a scaffold outside his banqueting hall in Whitehall Palace.
It's still there today.
The banqueting hall,
the only surviving building of Whitehall palace,
if you visited the room that you enter on the first floor is the former
banqueting hall itself.
The ceiling is decorated with a wonderful painting by Rubens of the apotheosis
of King James.
The first Charles's father is shown ascending into heaven.
It's a wonderful artistic statement of divine right monarchy.
And ironically it was under that painting.
The child's walked to step out from the window onto the scaffold wearing two
shirts because it was a cold January day in case he should shiver and people
might think he was afraid.
He met his death with great dignity,
perhaps knowing that this was the best thing he could do for the monarchy to die
well.
And so he did,
and as his head was struck off,
one witness says that from the crowd there came such a Groan as I never heard
before.
It's ironic for those of us who live in new haven,
that in Broadway we have a high Anglo Catholic Episcopalian Church,
which is one of those that recognizes the execution of King Charles.
The first,
uh,
commemorates it as a,
a martyrdom for the episcopal church.
And we have running from Broadway three streets named after three of the men who
signed his death warrant golf,
Molly and Dixwell.
So the fingerprints of these events are here.
What next?
They had tried and they had failed to reach a settlement with the king.
Could they achieve one without him?
Well,
it was attempted in March 16,
49 parliament declared the monarchy and the House of Lords abolished in May 16,
49,
England was declared a Commonwealth and Free State or rich,
what to run in the name,
not of the king,
but of the keepers of the liberties of England.
A new great seal was made for the kingdom,
which bore a picture not of the king,
but of the House of Commons in session surrounded around the edge with the
legend in the first year of freedom,
by God's blessing restored.
Well,
perhaps in time those lofty aspirations might have acquired some real substance,
but for the moment,
the fact was that this was a regime run by a committed minority,
supported by a somewhat larger body who were willing to conform to its authority
out of pragmatism or for the sake of order or out of mere political opportunism.
But despite its lofty claims,
the survival of the regime depended ultimately upon the army.
And the army of course had an agenda of its own above all defense of liberty,
of conscience for the godly and the pursuit of a rather vaguely defined godly
reformation in the kingdom.
These tensions where initially disguised by the fact that there was an immediate
need to defend the new regime
in 1649 to 50 parliament undertook the reconquest of Ireland to prevent its use
as a base by Charles the second now age 19 and in exile.
And that's reconquest was brutally initiated by Cromwell himself.
Cranwell was now appointed Lord General since the Thomas Fairfax,
after the execution of the king in which he had no part was not willing to go
any further,
and retired
Cornwell blended into Ireland with very little understanding of the complexities
of the Irish situation and blinded by the 1641 propaganda stereotype of the
barbarities committed by the Irish rebels at the fortress town of Draka attorney
or Dublin in 1649,
uh,
a massacre of the defenders of doctor was committed.
This was justified by the laws of war.
They had refused to surrender honorably and under the laws of war at the time,
a city taken by assault with the losses that that involved would be one which
would be permitted no quarter.
Nevertheless,
it was an act probably partly fueled by religious bigotry and zeal chrome
himself in the dispatch he sent back to England after [inaudible] appears
troubled by what he had ordered.
It has a very defensive tone.
Nonetheless,
it was done and it initiated a bloody pacification of Ireland,
which continued for two years and culminated in confiscations of land from Irish
landowners and the founding of a Protestant descendancy in Ireland with the land
being granted to adventurers who had given money for the reconquest and
soldiers.
It didn't create the Protestant island day envisaged.
It created a deeply divided society dominated by British land owners and the
roots of the subsequent animosity,
which remains even in the current fragile peace.
Meanwhile,
in 1650 Charles the second landed in Scotland where he was crowned King
Cromwell,
moved north to campaign there against Charles on the 3rd of September,
1650 he took on the army of the covenants at the battle of Dunbar,
heavily outnumbered his troops,
Hungary and many of them sick and nevertheless by a brilliant tactic of
attacking the central,
the Scottish line and splitting it.
They won an unexpected victory.
Again,
Cromwell exalted the Lord Hath done this.
He said in his dispatch,
a second Scottish invasion force was formed in the West and moved south.
Conwell then chased it down.
The east moved across and met them at Wooster.
A year after Dunbar were again on the 3rd of September.
Exactly a year later.
They were completely defeated.
The Battle of Wooster was described by chromium as the crowning mercy Charles
the second who had been with that army,
fled into exile again after the famous incident in which he hid in an oak tree
at boss scuttle house.
Wild parliamentarians soldiers search the grounds beneath for him story he liked
to tell later after he'd been restored to the crown
by 1653 the Commonwealth of England,
Scotland and Ireland created by these military actions and conquest constituted
the first or British state.
And meanwhile,
in 1652 to four of victorious naval war was fought against the Dutch.
Initially at the very foundation of the English Commonwealth.
The idea had been put forward a forming a union with the Dutch republic that had
been rejected and subsequent quarrels,
Dutch sheltering of Charles and trade rivalry led to a brief naval war in which
the Commonwealth was victorious.
So by 1653
the Commonwealth was militarily triumphant.
It's forces now battle hardened and possessed of the extraordinary morale which
had come from victory after victory or apparently invincible,
but with the peace tensions resurfaced.
This was not the popular regime which had been envisaged by the levelers.
It was not the godly regime which had been envisaged by Cromwells.
The rump had passed a toleration act in 1650 granting toleration and religious
sects of all kinds proliferate does.
You know,
some steps had been taken to improve the financial position of the clergy and
the church to get a better quality of clergy and some cosmetic reforms had been
made to the law.
But apart from that,
the rump showed little reforming zeal.
There was also a good deal of suspicion in the army that the members of the rump
planned to perpetuate themselves forever.
There was talk that when a seat fell vacant,
they would hold what were called recruiter elections for a single constituency
rather than holding a general election for the election of an entirely new
parliament,
the army didn't like that.
Finally on the 20th of April,
1653 when it appeared that the ramp was about to go ahead with that scheme,
Crum well who had been waiting patiently precipitately acted.
He stood up in parliament called in troops and dissolved the rump famously
declaring as he drove them out of their chamber be gone.
You have sat here too long for all the good you do.
What followed in the next five years was a series of constitutional experiments
in which Cromwells who now helps supreme power attempted to divest himself of
that power,
but at the same time retain the right to intervene when necessary to defend what
he took to be the central cause,
which to him meant above all liberty of conscience and rule by men of godly and
honest conversation as he put it.
The trouble was the two few others in the nation shared his aspirations and as
he later remarked to bolstered Whitlock one of his advisors.
I am as much for government by consent as any man,
but where will I find that consent?
His first attempt was to win consent by establishing a reforming government and
a so called nominated parliament of 140 members was established to promote godly
reformed.
The members were simply nominated.
Chrome well described this as a door to usher in those things that God has
promised.
He was quite enthusiastic about the idea.
It was the brainchild of one of his officers,
Major General Thomas Harrison.
This parliament,
the nominated parliaments,
sometimes known as bare bones parliament after one of its members sat between
July and December,
1653 and it did indeed begin to consider radical reforms in the law and the
abolition of compulsory tires in the church,
but even in the parliament of Godly men,
such steps occasion too much anxiety for most of the members.
In December,
1643 while some of the more radical members were attending a prayer meeting,
more conservative members of the nominated parliament seize the moment are
dissolved themselves and handed the power back to Cromwell.
Yeah.
Next.
Between 1654 in 1647 57 they attempted government under constitution called the
instrument of government.
This was based on the heads of the proposals which had been put to the king.
In 1647 Cranwell was head of state with the title of Lord Protector.
Government was to be in the hands of the Lord.
Protector advised by a council of state.
Parliaments were to be elected every three years,
and the Lord protector was denied the power to delay any legislation for more
than 30 days.
This provided a measure of stability,
but when the first parliament met under the instrument of government in 1654
it,
it immediately began to attack both the instrument itself and the religious
toleration,
which was so dear to Cromwell's heart.
Consequently,
he dissolved it at the first opportunity.
In 1655 the risk of Arrivalist uprising and the smaller attempted uprising in
the West country led to the experiment of appointing regional military governors
to govern the country.
Major generals were appointed for a variety of English regions.
They were to oversee government and to promote godly reformation.
This measure was bitterly resented by the county gentry,
and when parliament met again in 1656 they violently attacked it as sword
government.
Cranwell gave way.
Then in February,
1657 parliament presented him with what was called the humble petition and
advice,
a call upon him to restore the ancient constitution and to accept the crown.
It took three months to think about it and then in May,
1657 rejected the offer of the crab.
He used the phrase,
I will not build Jericho again.
But he accepted all the rest,
the protector with a council and try any El parliaments was continued,
but the ancient constitution was largely to restored,
including a so called other house,
a kind of House of Lords of nominated members.
Well,
Cromwells rejection of the crown when it was actually offered to him is perhaps
a test of his personal integrity,
but the truth was that as Lord Protector,
he was king in orbit name.
He was probably sincere in seeing himself as he described himself as a good
constable set to keep the peace of the parish and above all to preserve God's
cause of religious toleration.
Domestically,
his rule was relatively mild.
Roman Catholics were not persecuted.
He was much preoccupied with healing and settling.
He employed many ex royalists if they would accept his government abroad.
He was successful.
The protector took part in a brief war against Spain,
which involve the capture of Jamaica and also the distinction of the new model.
Army defeating the Spanish army at the battle of Dunkirk,
but it was not government by consent and to many of the political nation well
remained an unforgivable regicide
to some of those who had been his former allies.
He appeared to be a hypocritical opportunist.
John Lilburn,
the former leveler set of crumb.
Well,
he will weep how and call upon the Lord even while he does smite the under the
first rib
to still more people in the country.
He appeared to be the protector,
not have tend to conferences and English liberties,
but of wild religious secretaries and fanatics who threatened to turn the world
upside down and bring confusion in society above all the Quakers who in their
early more radical phase cause great alarm as they spread their message across
the kingdom.
And ultimately everyone knew that the entire regime still dependent above all
upon the swords of the new model army and army,
which was increasingly an army of professionals,
only Crum,
well himself could hold it all together
by the curious blend of pragmatism and militancy,
which characterized him and by of course the intense devotion which he inspired
in his troops.
And then on the 3rd of September,
1658 aged exactly 59 he suddenly died.
Well,
the rest of the story can be swiftly told.
In 1659 following crumb wells death,
it all collapsed.
He was succeeded as protector temporarily by his inadequate son Richard
Parliament.
Refuse to recognize Richard's authority.
In May,
1659 under pressure from the generals,
Richard resigned and the rump parliament was recalled in October,
1659 General John Lambert dissatisfied with its proceedings dissolved the rump
again.
There was the threat of chaos in the kingdom.
In December,
1659 General George Monk Commander in chief in Scotland decided to intervene.
He marched his troops south to restore authority.
That meant first of all,
after he arrived in London restoring the rump and then in February,
1660 readmitting admitting to parliament all survivors of the long parliament of
1640 all of them who are still alive,
all those who had been expelled for various reasons,
we're permitted to resume their seats
by now.
Almost everyone expected the restoration of the monarchy.
In March,
1660 the long parliament voted to dissolve itself at last and to hold free
elections in April,
1660 Charles the second appealed from exile in the Netherlands in an attempt to
allay the anxieties of his former opponents and issue the declaration of Breeder
in which he said that if restored,
he would promise to respect the liberties of parliament.
He would rule by the law,
he would extend a free pardon to all former enemies and he would grant liberty
of conscience.
This seem to allay all anxieties.
In April,
1660 the so called convention parliament met complete with the House of Lords
and on the 8th of May Charles the second was recognized as king.
A few weeks later on the 25th of May,
he was brought home on a battleship.
The flagship of the navy,
ironically named the nays be after the battle at which his father had lost the
first civil war.
It was swiftly renamed the royal sovereign,
so the revolution was over.
It had been defeated,
or one could say it had defeated itself,
but it would never be forgotten and it left a legacy.
First of all,
the restored monarchy under Charles the second lived under the shadow of the
events of the 1640s
these could never be forgotten.
There were tacit understandings about the acceptable limits of royal authority
and the stewards would do well to remember them.
Secondly,
the politicization of a much larger section of society,
which had been part and parcel the dynamic I was a dramatic events of the 1640s
and 1650s was not reversed.
It remained.
Thirdly,
the Church of England could never again and compost the sheer diversity of
English Protestantism.
The Church of England was restored,
but religious dissent was an enduring fact throughout the kingdom.
And finally,
there was a fourth legacy.
What professor Lawrence Stone described as an immensely rich reservoir of ideas
that were to echo and echo down the ages,
those ideas,
political ideas,
religious ideas generated by the events and the dilemmas of the 1640s and the
1650s where in a sense,
what really made the English revolution the first of the Great European and
Atlantic revolutions.
And of course he will be discussing those ideas in section as John Davenport put
it,
observing all this from afar in 1647 at the height of it all,
the light which has now discovered in England will never be holy put out.
Though I suspect that contrary opinions will prevail for a time he was right.
Okay.
Oliver Cromwells head.
We have time.
I'm following the restoration.
Uh,
Cromwells body was exhumed.
He died of course,
in 1658,
the body had been embalmed and he'd been buried in state.
Um,
his body was exhumed along with that if Henry item,
uh,
and they were diverted,
the bodies with Gibby did in public and Cromwells head was struck off.
Um,
it was put on a spike hi on the walls of Westminster Hall.
Uh,
where it remained for over 20 years until in a gale in 1684,
it disappeared.
Um,
it's thought that it was probably blown down and one of the guards took it and
sold it.
Um,
it's resurfaced in the 18th century in the cabinet of Curiosities of,
uh,
gentlemen.
Uh,
then it vanished again for awhile.
It resurfaced again at the end of the 18th century when it was put on public
exhibition and people paid to see it.
Um,
then later on in the 19th century came into the possession of a scholarly
antiquarian clergymen who looked after it,
um,
uh,
and passed it down in his family.
Eventually in the early 20th century,
um,
it was offered to his former college,
Sydney Sussex College,
Cambridge,
um,
extensive forensic examination was done of the head to see if it was probably,
if it was genuine.
Uh,
well it was a head no doubt about that.
They have is extensively forensically examined and an extensive report was
prepared.
Um,
well they decided that the balance of probability was it wasn't deed Chromo os
head.
Um,
it has a spike through it for stock,
which is one clue.
Um,
it's,
um,
uh,
it,
it had been embalmed.
Um,
there's still scraps of skin and hair.
the,
there was other forensic evidence consistent with criminal's death mask.
A plaster mask had been taking his face after his death and that we've even
pitting on the skull in places where his face was famously disfigured by
prominent awards.
Uh,
so they decided to probably was homeless had,
and it was eventually reburied in,
um,
almost 300 years after to be next zoomed in Sydney,
Sussex College,
Cambridge where it's still there.
Only the master of Sydney Sussex and the dean of the College Chapel knows
exactly where,
uh,
it's a closely guarded secret.
Um,
I knew someone who was elected master of Sydney Sussex a few years ago and did
suggest that it would be nice to know,
uh,
but,
it was telling very politely to get lost.
So it's a closely guarded secret.
It's still there.
Um,
so if you go to Cambridge and visit Sydney Sussex College and go into the chapel
area where it's probably varied,
um,
you may be walking over Cromwells head.
Um,
meanwhile,
in the hall of Sydney,
Sussex,
um,
beside the high table,
they have a portrait of Commonwealth,
um,
Watson to all,
uh,
he famously told a portrait painter,
that he didn't want to be prettied up,
paint me warts and all he said,
uh,
and he is there and the portrait has curtains.
And if a member of the royal family happens to visit Sydney Sussex,
which happens from time to time,
they draw the curtains across Cromwells portrayed in order not to cause
embarrassment.
Um,
but the rest of the time the curtains are open and he looks down on the students
of his former college,
um,
who probably know little of his career.
But,
uh,
there is,
I make of him what you will either a cynical power,
hungry,
hypocritical opportunist or the defender of what people still refer to as the
good old cause.
Or as one biography described him,
God's Englishman.
But there we are.
So next week we will turn to the restoration regime.